and welcome back to Long Prime daily
everybody so we are bringing you a new
trial out of Illinois where the
defendant is representing himself 10 men
two women they were selected to be on
the jury in Springfield Illinois to
decide whether Bradley young is guilty
or not he's charged with home invasion
aggravated kidnapping vehicular
hijacking burglary and sexual assault
from a 2021 incident police say that yon
and accomplice Karen Blackledge used a
stolen car to carjack sexually assault
and Rob 77 year old Tina Schmidt she
died a month after the incident but
prosecutors aren't pursuing murder
charges in this case black ledge already
entered a guilty plea last year to
charges of home invasion and aggravated
criminal sexual assault with the rest of
the charges being dropped she's
currently serving 40 years in prison Jon
took a different route choosing to
represent himself in his own case and
that case started on Tuesday so let's
hear what the prosecution and yon
himself told the jury during opening
state
Tina thought it was about taking money
and jewelry from her she thought the
defendant was going to kill her so she
told her she had more stuff at back at
her house the defendant was not just
satisfied with money or jewelry the
defendant wanted more from this 77 year
old great grandmother while the
defendant was doing all of these things
robbing her assaulting her his
accomplice the woman that was with him
was holding a knife
and threatening Tina's life
after the defendant finished robbing
Tina of her dignity he fled he went
across the river to Hannibal
and he played video poker for the weeks
after her assault Tina was in pain both
emotional pain and physical pain
she never had the opportunity to recover
because on December 12 2021
Tina's heart broke these things
do not follow the definition of logic I
will show you what coercing manipulation
and deceit is persons think it is
absolutely funny to be vindictive to lie
to place forth claims and that would be
from the horse's mouth I will prove to
you reason for false testimony
from some who may or may not testify
throughout this adventure I'll show you
how other law enforcement think these
events that are alleged to have happened
are quite odd themselves stating such in
an indirect way
that is law enforcement and I intend to
prove that to you
so Brian there's an old saying that the
lawyer who represents himself has a fool
for a client is that true of Mr Young
Jesse this is not like when I tell my
wife I can do the the plumbing in the
house and I fix a few things and for the
record I did a pretty good job it's very
different to be an attorney for yourself
you don't understand the rules of
decorum you don't have a relationship
with the with a prosecutor or the judge
and a defense attorney acts as a shield
in the way that they can say certain
things because they're not the person on
trial that a client can't for themselves
so it's very difficult and I do think
the old adage does hold true that this
is a bit of a foolish Endeavor now in
the clip we sent our producers told us
hey I sent the most articulate portion
of this guy talking but in the rest of
his opening statement it was foolish and
I think it might be his downfall I don't
think it's going to help him but we'll
watch we've already seen other cases
summer and I think what was the other
one
um Daryl Brooks yeah didn't work out for
that that did not work out so well Dina
I feel like this is a prosecutor's dream
though does it make it easier for them
to win the case here and based on their
opening how tight's their case
I mean it absolutely makes it easier
because he's going to be so bad at
defending himself it's as if there is no
defense and I think their case is seems
pretty strong to begin with and that's
probably why he's willing to represent
himself I'm sure his defense attorney
was kind of giving him uh realistic odds
and they weren't very good so he was
willing to kind of roll the dice and
maybe he was inspired by Daryl Brooks
Daryl Brooks kind of became a viral
sensation and if you think hey I'm going
to get prosecuted convicted at the end
of this maybe I'm gonna go down and
become viral myself who knows what his
thinking is but it's certainly a bad
idea if you actually want to get
acquitted yeah no one's talking about
Daryl Brooks anymore that that 15
minutes of fame is sure up when we come
back the life of a Texas border patrol
agent lies in the hands of a jury as his
penalty phase continues for the deaths
of his mistress and Son we'll bring you
the very latest from the courtroom next
[Music]
oh
we're finishing Today's Show in Laredo
Texas where day three continues in the
penalty phase of a former border patrol
agent faces life in prison or death row
for a gruesome double homicide allegedly
over child support money Ronald Anthony
Burgos Aviles was convicted by a jury
last week for the 2018 deaths of his
mistress Griselda Hernandez and their
one and a half year old son Dominic
prosecutors argued that Dominic was born
while the defendant was having an affair
and Hernandez served him child support
documents
now because of that prosecutors say he
stabbed Hernandez and the baby to death
after meeting up with them near a park a
week of evidence is expected as part of
the penalty phase the jury will then
hand down a recommendation for either
the death penalty or life in prison
without parole on Tuesday a mental
health specialist from the Webb County
Jail testified for the prosecution and
he talked about his mental health
assessment of the defendant which
happened more than a month after his
arrest here's his response when
questioned by both sides
correct
no anxiety correct no sleep problems
correct no depression correct no
suicidal ideation that is correct the
only thing that he complained there was
first his other it may be nice
current depressive symptoms anxiety
auditory visual hallucinations suicidal
homicidal ideations or dead wishes
no history of suicide attempts reported
stated has been sleeping and eating fine
you may behave appropriate to do an
interview no active psychotic future
detected no signs on mental
decompensation were evident and all this
stress noted from your opinion and
understanding psychosis is a Continuum
right it's a progression is that correct
correct there's no way to for you to
observe whether or not is thinking and
thought processes have been effective
correct
when I saw him his thoughts like it says
in the report the word coherent logical
and organization you're not you're not
claiming to be a mind reader right no no
definitely not
you took six undergraduate classes in
Psychology is that correct correct I
just want to make sure all right you're
not giving any clinical impressions are
you no okay as a matter of fact you need
a license to give clinical Impressions
is that correct correct
Dina let's back up for a second why is
the defendant's mental health important
during this penalty phase
I mean the mental health is based
resource and it's a mitigating
that yes we they've already proved
intent this isn't a matter of like
saying that he was insane and he
couldn't have committed the crime that
level of mental health but it's yes he
did this intentionally but his
background was such that he deserves to
be in prison for life rather than killed
because of it because sometimes we talk
about childhood abuse and then in this
case whether or not mentally he had some
issues but it seems here this expert is
trying to say that he didn't but we'll
see the defense probably kind of putting
up their own expert talking a little bit
more saying that he deserves the kind of
compassion and mitigating factor to get
life in prison but here in Texas as we
know it's the number one state for
executions so whether or not the jury
will be that sympathetic we'll see well
Brian does the witnesses credentials
does that have any bearing on his
opinion Jesse
18 hours and it is your minor in college
hey when someone asks me Brian do you
speak French I always say
I took more I took more college credits
in French and this guy did in Psychology
and he's trying to give a diagnosis I
don't think it works so to that I can't
think of any more French things to say
because I only took so many credits I
don't think it holds water prosecutor
find someone better find someone took 20
credits I don't know but this doesn't
seem to be enough to push him past that
limit in terms of a death penalty
analysis but they have plenty of other
evidence that they can use yeah and we
sometimes ignore the credentials of
these Witnesses but they're important
and juries pay attention Dina Bryan
thank you so much everyone out there
thanks for joining us here on Long crime
daily we're going to see you next time
as we discuss Justice in America
foreign